pour boucler cette 1re édition du
journal de 20h du 21e siècle
retour sur les 2000 coups de minuit qui
marquaient hier soir la place du centre
pompidou à paris n'est normes roulement
de tambour venus de neuf pays d'europe
reportage béatrice blondeau marie cazaux
et mathieu dreujou
nagy d'une musique légère avant la
charge lourde des 1000 tambour pour
entrer dans le troisième millénaire
ils sont venus de neuf pays d'europe
des musiciens parfois professionnels
souvent amateurs pour un spectacle
grandiose
deux ans que nous sommes ce spectacle et
que nous avons fait le tour de l'europe
pour trouver un homme il s'embourbe pour
eux pour faire un fond faire voler tous
nos mobiles
est ce vraiment la réunion du swing de
l'europe
malgré la pluie le public a répondu
présent
remy personnes c'était henry tout le
nouveau millénaire